you've
spoken about him before i think it'd be
nice to maybe honor him
to break it apart a little bit aaron
schwartz yeah
uh why was he a special human being in
this
ilk of what we're talking about now
civil disobedience um
how do we honor him now moving forward
as human beings
who are willing to take risks in this
world
well i don't know i mean are you
inspired by aaron schwartz
i am how do you feel about jstor let's
talk about jstor first
so let's let's let's say what jstor is
all about
we the taxpayer pay for research
and then
the people who do the research do all
the work for a bunch of companies
who then charge us thirty dollars an
article
to read what it is that we already paid
for and if we don't cite these articles
we're told that we're in violation okay
i almost never call for civil
disobedience because i don't really want
to
but [ __ ] jstor
[ __ ] elsevier [ __ ] springer who the [ __ ]
are these people yeah
get the smart people
need to take the greedy people
behind the woodshed and explain to them
what science is
i have a very old-fashioned idea that's
so out of favor
that i will immediately be seen as
knuckle dragger yeah
i believe in the great woman theory of
history and the great man theory of
history
emmy nerder is fantastic
as an example and i believe in
editors over peer reviewers and i
believe that
wrong things should be allowed into the
literature and i believe that the
gatekeeping should go towards zero
because the costs associated with
distribution
are very very slight i believe that um
we should be looking at the perverse
incentives of sending
your paper blindly into your
competitor's clutches particularly if
you're a young person
being reviewed by an older person uh are
you familiar with the
the dua de senor are you familiar with
the legend of the magnia
now the magna is the miller's daughter
and the largest
food fight in the entire universe i
believe
is held i think in italy uh it's called
the battle of the oranges
and it celebrates the miller's daughter
who had fallen in love with her beloved
and when it came time for them to marry
the virginal magnaya was in fact
told that the lord of the land
had the right to have the first night
with the bride
well the magnaya had a different idea so
she seemed to consent to this
uh perhaps mythical right also called
the
the primonote the first night and
by by legend she concealed a dagger
underneath her robes
and when it came time for the hated lord
of the manor to extract
this right she pulled the knife out and
killed him
and i think it also echoes a little bit
of particularly wonderful scene from
game of thrones
but that inspired both men and women and
the magnaya is the legendary hero
right now what we need to do is we need
to resist the primo note the right of
first look
right fu you don't have to write a first
look i don't want to send something
blindly to my competitors i don't want
to subject myself to you naming what
what work i've done why why are you in
my story
that's my question get out of my story
if i do work
and then you have an idea oh well it's
the matthew principle to him
uh who has much more will be given i've
gone to the national academy of sciences
and talked about these things and it's
funny i've been laughed at by the older
people
who think well eric you know science
precedes
funeral by funeral that's plonk you know
the matthew
principle you know the matilda principle
the things done by women are attributed
to men
these are not new you're like and you
guys just live like this
yeah so the revolutionary act now
knowledge to resist all of these things
that
we need these things that are not new so
you asked me about aaron schwartz aaron
schwartz was the magnia
you